good morning and good afternoon everyone
out there an Internet thank you so much
for joining us today we'd really
appreciate it
English URI I'm a custom engineer here
at Google and I'm joined by my partner
in bearded Miss and laptop sticker
collection Nick hey how's it going
you're not yeah I'm definitely happy to
be here I know that we have exciting
topics to cover today as you mentioned
my name is Nick oil if I'm also a
customer engineer and we are fortunate
enough to have one of our amazing
rockstars Karthi on Karthi you wanna
introduce yourself hey Nick and Yuri so
yeah my name is karthika Rajan
I won't expect you to say my last name
I'm a Solutions Architect based out of
Dallas and I've got serious dhikr in me
because all I have is this Google
Analytics well listen man you got a long
time before you can catch up to us I
tend to be a sticker maximalist so I'm
pretty much just collecting whatever I
can get my hands on now you're not a
whole lot of the discretion being
applied so first you thank you so much
for being here with us you know you
introduced yourself as a solution
architect can you give us like a
30-second summary of what is a solution
architect do at Google yeah great
question in a lot of ways you know we
are very similar to a customer engineer
and one of the key differences of course
is that we focus on specific customers
we work with various areas of specialty
in my case it's Big Data so I focus on
streaming data along with actually
streaming and batch and then quite a bit
of app dev as well so for example if a
customer wants to figure out how they
can leverage data flow to do both stream
processing as well as batch processing
you know and they have a lot of
experience will stay doing hive on Prem
I would basically work with them to
translate some of the existing
implementations to doing it in a more
cloud native fashion so that's an
example of what a Solutions Architect
would do I mean when it comes to what's
valuable to a company number one is
definitely their data and their
employees so being able to extract some
useful information and new insights from
that data is
we powerful so I'm sure you must be a
very busy guy you can say that again
yeah and once again we appreciate you
being with us so as you can imagine you
know a lot of the questions that we get
are around how do customers make use of
their data some of the questions that
I've been hearing more recently are not
just about how do people make use of the
data basically at the end of their data
pipeline or are the other that are
processing or how could they can
actually answer some questions about
what's going on with their data before
it even gets to its final destination
know we talked a lot about it now
obviously we're at AI first company but
people want to know how do they get
sense out of the stuff that's going on
in their environment you know before
they have a chance to train and deploy a
machine learning model so I'm really
happy that you're today because what I
want to hear from you is kind of what
you're seeing customers do especially
where different roles within an
organization are concerned to actually
utilize their data at all of the
different stages of the pipeline or the
lifecycle does that make sense yeah yeah
absolutely I think that is something
that I've heard on multiple occasions as
well so happy to get into it all right
let's do that right and you know as
based on past meetups I want to
emphasize before I get into the slides
that the slide portion will be pretty
light and I think that's a good thing
we'll get into demos after about four or
five slides so to start out with I'll
kind of reinforce eyes the fact that
this discussion kind of came out of make
myself and Yuri talking about the data
lifecycle solution that we put out but
you know you can google data lifecycle
on GCP you'll find it it should be the
first link that shows up the the key
here is there are many stages that make
up the data lifecycle you know starting
with collect ingest all the way to
visualize but the focus of this
discussions we will kind of talk about
the personas and even within the
personas will will focus on what a data
scientist
does and as Yuri pointed out earlier
well we'll look at how we can surface in
sites from you know let's say the vast
amounts of data that any typical
enterprise gathers but I also want to
point out that you know data doesn't
necessarily mean that it should be
limited to data scientists or analysts
you know you'll also have software
developer or system architects etc who
you know have say-so as well as
decision-making ability when it comes to
how data progresses through the
lifecycle yeah so well as I mentioned
while we won't touch on the software
developer side of things I just want to
mention you know this is a familiar flow
that most folks kind of have been seeing
for I would say at least 50 years now
ever since the advent of computers you
know there's some kind of data
collection going on they'll store it in
relational database of some sort and
then they'll visualize it so this is the
simplest kind of kind of flow that most
people are familiar with so take it a
little further now what we're getting
into is the fact that data has become so
much more valuable than this previous
slide would indicate data kind of
becomes the engine for entire businesses
and what we'll what we're hoping to do
today is give you some insight into why
that is and so in this space you'll see
the persona of the data scientists and
analysts kind of playing a much more
significant role so you know looking at
this right now because the the flow of
the software developer basically ends
with the store step and that's where
someone like a data scientist or data
analyst would actually pick it up so I
think you know the key point here is
that depending on who you are there are
different things you need to do with the
data there's different kinds of analysis
you might want to do because even the
software development me developer may
need to use the data that's flowing to
their system to understand things like
system performance issues that may be
taking place or things that could be
potentially negatively impacting user
experience your honor and I know that
that software developer role or persona
is not necessarily the focus of what
you'll be covering we'll be talking more
about kind of the
personas in this particular session but
it's only one folks to think about you
know how do they expose data in their
environment to everyone that might
benefit from it yep that's right and and
yeah another takeaway takeaway I would
say is you know it is super important
for these personas to work together and
the roles are often blurred as you know
as you would agree because I've often
seen data scientists who where the
software developer hat when it comes
time to take all the experimentation
they've done with the store and say ok
now I got to productize this I got to
put this out in production and let's say
expose a machine-learning endpoint that
can be called by all these other
services so at that point you know you
you have kind of a blurring of personas
as well carry on cool so as I mentioned
before we get into the demo let's just
look at this very simple flow
essentially what we're gonna do is we're
gonna create a toy example and it starts
with this simple driver program that we
created that dumps a whole bunch of
orders into pub/sub these are orders
that have some basic information as
we'll see like the name of the person
that made the order as well as a widget
ID that indicates that they ordered this
particular widget so it'll go through
prob sub it'll be processed by data flow
and then from data flow we'll put it
into bigquery and so that's the store
face and once it lands in bigquery this
is where a business let's say any Annie
Taylor and a retailer can start to make
sense of the kinds of purchasing
decisions that are being made by
customers and one of obviously the key
key insights there is how our customers
deciding what to buy right this is a
question that often gets asked asked so
we'll look at some ways of creating
models that help us predict some of
those purchasing decisions and we'll use
something called data lab which is
essentially a hosted Jupiter notebook
and this is usually the realm of data
scientists and from data lab what we'll
do is once we've kind of honed the model
we'll deploy that model to a fully
managed server list machine learning
system called cloud machine learning
engine does that sound good guys sounds
great yeah definitely looking forward to
it stick it to the data one thing I am
besides here is that we've actually
covered a lot of these components or
product in other sessions you know I did
a session on streaming so folks if you
folks want to learn more about how
pops-up works how you can go about
writing beautiful o transforms how big
we works you know we've certainly got a
lot of collateral on that and done
sessions on on this very meet up to
cover those so you know I don't want to
miss I spend too much time on the
infrastructure piece of this so how do
you actually get the data flowing I
think the key thing we're going to keep
emphasizing and keep thinking the key
thing I'm gonna be coming back to as we
keep talking I'll perhaps twenty minutes
or so is how do we use the data at each
step rather than how do we get the data
to flow yeah no that's a great point
yeah yeah with that in mind you know I
won't spend any time on actually I'll
spend very little time on the ingest
piece and the processing piece with the
understanding that you know folks
already have kind of seen this presented
on this very beat up so what I'll do is
let me just quickly touch on the nature
of the data that's flowing through the
system so this is some Python code and
I've kept it simple so all I'm going to
show here is is that we have an order ID
in order to create a date the name of
the customer something called you know
something that takes the place with a
customer phone number and then the
widget ID as I mentioned so this is
these are the fields that you kind of
have to keep in mind as the data flows
through this system is we inspect it
each of these life cycle stages and let
me also quickly show the data flow
processes and the key takeaway here is
how simple it is to write a dataflow job
all we're doing here is we're
subscribing to a pub sub topic and
essentially ask the messages come in we
are putting them into bigquery
you have quite a bit of flexibility as
far as what you could do with filtering
and you know maybe and reaching the data
as it's flowing through the system we're
not doing that so with that said let's
quickly look at what's in a query so
that we can then look at what we can do
with that data so as you mentioned I'm
sure you're familiar with the bigquery
UI this is this meetup demo des is the
data set that I've created and within
that data set I have a table called
bigquery demo table essentially that
table mirrors the kind of the payload
that I showed you earlier okay and I've
got quite a few records here so now
let's look at what a data scientists
would want to do with this data and this
is where you know a data scientist is
perfectly comfortable dealing with a
data warehouse like bigquery however
they also want the power of something
like Jupiter notebook you know a lot of
data scientists work in are in Python
etcetera in this in this case we'll
focus on on Python with with Jupiter
notebook so Drupa to notebook has it's
kind of ancestry inside Python they
renamed it and now you know you have all
of that kind of power available to you
as a hosted service and the name of that
service is cloud data laughing and the
way you interact with data lab is
actually with the CLI there is a de UI
within the GCP console you can get to so
essentially what you would have to do is
install the lab CLI and once you get to
the CLI you have the ability to create a
data lab instance and then you can
connect to it so as I mentioned you have
create connect list etc so let's look at
they lab list to see how many data lab
instances I have running as you can see
here I have one one instance running and
it's in the US central
and by the way you can also specify the
machine type that you would like for
certain kinds of number-crunching you
may want a bigger instance in this case
I've kind of gone with the standard -
you know four which is a little bit
bigger than what you get by default so
let me pause there real quick
Nik and yuri do you guys have anything
that that you want me to kind of focus
on before I get to the actual notebook
itself actually I have one question I'm
so you're talking about from the overall
pipeline perspective the data is gonna
be streaming through pubs up and then
going data flow and that at the end is
basically piling into the data warehouse
being bigquery supposed to support
streaming directly into the basically
into your into your bigquery table I'm
using the streaming API do you mind
talking about some of the pros and cons
of going your route of streaming through
pub/sub and then data flow versus
directly to bigquery yeah that's a great
that's a great point so one reason that
comes to mind as to why you could go you
should go with pub/sub is if you want
more flexibility and let's say in
filtering or transforming the data you
know if you have requirements that you
know require kind of heavy
transformations against the data before
it lands the store like bigquery I would
definitely recommend that you go with
you know putting data flow in the middle
for simple ingest scenarios I think it's
perfectly okay to kind of leave out data
flow but usually in an enterprise kind
of scenario that's not the case yeah
that makes sense especially when you're
scaling up so okay how about you any
questions ago there we go awesome okay
so let's get to let's get to the
notebook itself so so real quick you
know I already have a notebook kind of
running and connected so when you run
data lab Connect and give it the name of
the actual data lab instance what it
does is it creates an SSH tunnel and
then it automatically pops up a browser
window like I've done here and you can
see here that the address is localhost
8080 when you can change the sport to
you know
another report if you so choose but this
makes it really easy to connect to this
essentially separate VM with all the
goodies installed so we're talking you
know numpy we're talking tensorflow
everything that a data scientist would
want and to continue with the kind of a
quick tour of what this notebook gives
you if you were to start this up what
you can do is let me just sorry let me
just scroll up here and show you that
what you have here with data lab is
essentially a managed service that
anybody who who has access to that
project can connect to so every time
somebody opens a notebook what they get
is a separate kernel that runs the
notebook that they're looking at and
once you're done essentially if you're
you know kind of see in the resource
usage for that instance is heavy you can
shut down that notebook so that you're
bringing up memory CPU usage etcetera
question I imagine that some folks on
the line may or may not be familiar they
probably I'm sure they've heard of
Python but yeah is a bit of a different
paradigm right lots of people are
familiar with writing Python code in an
IDE tell us a little bit about why like
why do people use Jupiter what is it
given that you know doesn't know another
great question so one of the big things
is you essentially get this ability to
mix markdown and actual code so that
even if you yourself were the only one
working in this kind of notebook you
have kind of self-documenting code so
let me you know if I were to open up
this guy here
introduction to notebooks and this is by
the way this is all kind of built into
data lab you can open up these examples
and play with it so you can see this
looks like a webpage it's very well
documented you find a cell and you put
in your Python code and you hit ctrl
enter or you can just click on run and
it actually runs the code
and all of it is documented you can save
it you can share these notebooks with
other people so it's the collaboration
and the self documenting aspect of it I
would say is one of the most powerful
things about doing it this way where
Smurfs is running it in an IDE like
PyCharm awesome yeah very much so
alright so now how do we use data in pub
supper and bigquery within Jupiter
yeah that's definitely one of the one of
the significant kind of capabilities
with data Lab is the integration is
built-in so for example there are these
Jupiter notebook by the way it gives you
the ability to run these magic commands
that's what they're called and what the
data lab folks have done is they've kind
of enhanced that to add the ability to
integrate with DCP services let's say
queries so this is a magic command here
you know it's % % BQ query and then what
I can do is submit a query like I went
into the bigquery UI and then I get the
results right here and that integration
is really powerful because what you can
then do on top of this is now you can
bring in the power of all the other kind
of number crunching
you know visualization capabilities so
as an example what I've done here is
I've created this variable
sorry it's called the up in this case DF
to signify that it's a data frame so the
native scientists amongst you know the
audience will recognize data frames and
data frames obviously come with really
powerful you know thing of finds
capabilities for lack of a better phrase
so you can populate this data frame and
then you can go on as I've done here to
do some more visualization so what I've
done is I've taken this data frame and
essentially what I'm trying to do here
is model the relationship between the
person who put it in order and the type
of widget it is just to see if I can
actually use it for predictive analytics
so this is you know both goes to
illustrate the power of combining you
know all the GCP services as you
mentioned URI along with what you know
data lab has in terms of capabilities so
in this case I take the data out of the
bigquery query that I did and then I'm
plotting it so you can see that there's
a linear relationship between you know
the name of the person that put in an
order and the widget ID and obviously
this is a contrived example but but this
gives you an idea of how you can do some
visualization directly against the data
and bigquery very cool all right so I
think that gives us a great perspective
on like the data scientists experience
in GCP know using data from bigquery as
it first arrives either directly from
pubs up streaming or from a data flow
transform you know what other persona
Geo in mind for taking advantage of data
if I'm a different lighthouse up steps
of the pipeline over the life cycle yeah
so if we were to kind of you know go
beyond just this ability to experiment
you know you have the analyst who has to
let's say actually implement actually
before I get to be a analyst let's talk
about let's talk about the system
architect who has to maybe implement the
kind of the predictive analytics that a
data scientist has gleaned from from
this graph here so you know the data
scientist says oh I I have a lightbulb
moment year I know that this is how
customers are making decisions on what
to order
so lettuce now actually create a machine
learning model that will take all this
training data all this gold basically
and suggest widgets for customers to buy
so to implement this at scale what a
system architect would have to do is
essentially go to this training data
that's in bigquery and say okay I'm
going to do some feature engineering and
to do this at scale a product that that
we recently released is called Dana prep
so if you're cool with it
Yuri shall we moved today to prep and
kinda talk
about what that can do for us yeah
absolutely I'm really interested in
seeing you know how now that we
understand sort of the like the life of
the data scientist on TV I think we want
to see yeah what does like how there's
an architect benefit from this data as
well yeah I've run into frequently is
just that the data comes in all jumbled
and there's really no way of simply
simply cleaning it up and preparing it
so love to see what you can do awesome
cool so so as we discussed we have this
data that's in bigquery so let's pull up
data prep and extract essentially what
are call features that will help us do
some predictions and a picture is worth
a thousand words so let's actually
create something called a flow what a
flow is is you can think of it as a
transform it helps you take raw data and
kind of shape it into something that you
can use for a machine learning model
because often times you can't just take
roz Ada and apply training to it because
the data is probably not going to be in
you know in a shape that you want so
let's do a very uncreated name for for
this flow here and and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna add a data set that is
going to be the source data set for this
transformation that we talked about and
for that I'm going to pick a source so
as you can see to start off with you can
either either pull a GCS object or you
can go to bigquery as the source and you
can pick a table in this case we're
going to pick this table which is where
the order data landed once we've picked
the source what we can then do is we can
edit kind of the way the transformation
functions and we can do it in a visual
kind of UI based fashion and this is one
of the key capabilities of data Pro
you're not writing a bunch of code which
there's nothing wrong with writing code
but a lot of times it's hot
for people to picture what the data
looks like and that's one of the really
powerful aspects of data prep so we have
the source data so we we create
something called a recipe and a recipe
is something that essentially applies to
the data and let's edit this recipe to
kind of tell it what to do with with the
raw data here as you can tell it's
loading the demo table that I created
and I'm sure you'll recognize all these
columns you know it's the same columns
that I showed you in that Python class
order ID or to create a date etc and
right off the bat we little notices data
prep does a good job of adding visual
indicators to the data so for example
you know it'll tell me this name
Jennifer Smith occurs points or 4% in
the whole dataset so these are really
cool but what's even more powerful is
it'll tell me hey there are different
kind of shapes for customer phone number
and also that there are 19 25 rows that
don't have customer phones so you can
see there's a lot of power here in kind
of giving you the ability to filter
leave out things that may not be helpful
a really important point there is that
it you can quickly understand you know
what does the data look like
do I have outliers are there gaps so you
know you're let's say that the thing
York you were trying to figure out is
you know folk the location of your
customers phone number might be a really
important piece of information there
because the area kill it gives you very
precise location information if you
don't have GPS data or anything like
that and if that's the key part of what
you're doing then having some
significant portion of your data and not
have a phone number makes it somewhat
less useful that's right and just out of
curiosity it seems like this does a lot
of the transformational piece that data
flow also drives so what's the
relationship between data prep and data
flow great point
data data prep is actually built on top
of data flow and the reason that
significant is that once you kind of as
will do here once you kind of create
this transform it is actually run within
slow which means we can we can deal with
hundreds of terabytes or even pediments
of data because of the scale out
capabilities that dataflow brings to the
table awesome that's interesting so yeah
so what's actually I'm sorry to
interrupt you I you know in the interest
of keeping this to a manageable length
because I think we could easily be here
for an hour or two hours talking about
everything I think this is the
visibility with Dana prep gives folks
really excellent understanding of how
they can go about doing some of that
data wrangling and data cleanup and then
like you said right creating those
transforms that would then you know make
this data more useful or actually clean
about automatically so let me ask you to
shift gears a little bit let's talk
about that last persona that we want it
to cover yeah so essentially this is
this is the persona that kind of brings
together you know the machine learning
sorry the data Sciences with we know
with the machine learning models as well
as the analyst and then also the system
architect in this case this is the
person implementing the entire system
and then bringing it online so it can do
online prediction assistance and things
of that nature so I'll segue to that
persona by talking about how data prep
can be leveraged to generate the raw
data to do the Michigan learning so so
in this case I've picked out all the raw
data that doesn't have missing order IDs
for whatever reason and then I run this
dataflow job and as Nick pointed out
sorry is its data prep job as Nick
pointed out just to show you when you
run a data prep job it actually shows up
in data flow as you can see here and
this just confirms the fact that
underneath the covers data prep is
actually using dataflow okay so with
that said let's now jump back to our
Jupiter notebook and kind of look at our
you know kind of system architect
persona how they would take a machine
learning model that the data scientist
has put together and how they will
generate
a prediction edge for predictive
analytics all right sounds great awesome
cool so you know this is gonna be very
light in terms of actual machine
learning modeling I mean this is a very
unsophisticated model just for
demonstration purposes so keep that in
mind anyway so the data scientist has
determined that there's a very simple
linear relationship between the name of
the person it's making the order and the
widget that ends up getting ordered so
what what we're gonna do is we will take
the cleansed data the data prep puts
into a GCS bucket it's in the CSV file
let me select it here and with that what
we will do is we will create a training
data set as well as a test data set and
this is actually how you know tensorflow
typically works this you have to have a
training data set and then you train
your model with a certain number of
iterations and then you test that model
with the test data set to make sure that
things aren't out of whack cool so the
way you do that without going into too
many of the details is you basically you
know as I mentioned you basically create
the training data set and the test data
set and then you leverage something
called an estimator this is built into
tensorflow and you can have a variety of
estimators that you can pick from in
this case we'll use a simple you know
regression when your regression model
here to to train and we'll set up inputs
that come from the training data set
that we talked about and essentially
after that we we say hey let's run this
training for 300 steps and one
evaluation that goes against the test
dataset that I mentioned with all of
that kind of put into this task Python
file what we can then do is try out the
model local
and all I have to do is run the model
this is by the way not running on ml
engine even though it is referencing ml
engine what this is doing is you know
taking the training data and running it
in my data lab instance so that's
important to remember
once that's you know satisfactory we
were happy with the model performance
things like that we can actually run it
in the cloud and the way the flow would
go is so the system architect let's say
what would try this out in the cloud and
they would leverage the kind of power of
the GCC cloud they have the ability to
pick a whole bunch of scale tiers as
some of you may know training is often
the most time-consuming aspect of you
know doing predictive analytics because
it requires some serious horsepower and
this is where you know being able to
tell you know go quiet machine learning
engine hey I want to use 10 machines or
I want to use three GPUs you can specify
all of that here when you're doing the
training in the cloud you may bring in
terabytes of data to do that training so
then you know the training is done you
also then have the ability to kind of
look at the characteristics of I
apologize I I have to rerun this again
but basically if you guys are familiar
with tensor board you have the ability
to kind of look at where the model lands
and all the characteristics of the
training and you can inspect it with
tensor board so that'll tell you hey
this is the lost function this is how
long it took to run things of that
things of that nature once you've run
the model and you're happy with it
you can deploy it and what does
deployment mean so deployment has to do
with actually having cloud machine
learning engine once again it's fully
serverless we're not talking about you
know individual computers or your own
managed cluster we're talking about a
managed service hosting the model for
you and then you can have it do
predictions in the way that works is you
essentially tell it hey this is where my
model is
after you know training is complete in
this case it landed in this when I say
it
machine learning engine after the
training is complete landed the model in
this GCS bucket that you specified and
basically you can take that model and
then use it to do predictions and what
we're gonna do here is basically pass it
inputs just to see hey what kind of
predictions am I getting so this is
something we can actually do because
I've deployed the model with machine
learning engine and you can do it you
can do it actually directly from data
lab that's one of the cool things about
using data lab is you don't have to exit
this environment the data scientists are
probably comfortable in or also system
architects and leverage the model that
you've deployed to production to do some
predictions let me pause there well
quick while this is running and see if
there any additional questions that I
can address yeah anything on the live
stream we don't have any questions in
the live stream but I think this is
actually this may be a great place to
wrap it up thank you so much for showing
us how data can flow through a pipeline
in GC p thanks for showing us how to
make sense of it you know kind of as it
arrives in bigquery and some of that
first level of analytics you can do just
with things like sequel queries probably
do that next level of analysis as a data
scientist using hosted jupiter service
with cloud data lab how to make sure the
data is good and clean and useful the
data prep and then how to take it to the
next level with either local ml or a
cloud ml engine I thought this was
fantastic really useful information
Thank You Karthik really appreciate your
time like you said at the start you're
you're a busy man and would really
appreciate you taking the time out to
talk to us yeah absolutely really
enjoyed it thank you for your time
all right folks thank you so much as
always like rate and subscribe right
that's what you're saying when you're a
Youtube no and they can all we do we'll
be back next week with another DCP
customer story please tune in then will
you've done the schedule already or will
get on the schedule as soon as possible
thanks everyone have a great day and
we'll talk to you soon
yep until next time thanks